Колись давно тут проходив кордон
між Західним та Східним Берліном
Колись тут стояли один напроти одного
радянські та американські танки
Тут гинули люди, намагаючись втекти на Захід
Сьогодні тут - своєрідний стихійний Діснейленд імені холодної війни"
матрьошки, кашкети, химерні сувеніри та одягнені в американську форму аніматори
які за три євро фотографуються з туристами
Це стало об’єктом критики громадянської ініціативи
до якої долучилися два колишніх мери Берліна
Критики вважають цю ситуацію “непристойною”
та вимагають створення музею холодної війни
Організатори ініціативи показали свій план того
яким має бути колишній КПП “Чарлі”
менше кітчу, більше серйозного осмислення історії
Зокрема і новий музей, принципове рішення
про створення якого
ухвалили ще 12 років тому
Але відтоді, як це нерідко буває в Берліні
нічого не змінилося
Автори ініціативи переконані
символічне місце у середмісті Берліна
має нарешті відповідати своїй ролі в історії
і що вже час оголосити архітектурний конкурс
на проект музею
Це діра. Це тріщина посеред міста
Я би не використовував слово "непристойно"
Але про плани забудови кварталу
йдеться вже 30 років
Було вже дві спроби
дві компанії з якихось невідомих мені причин
не впоралися з цим
А тепер фірма "Трокланд"
яка придбала ділянку з майна
збанкрутілої ірландської компанії
намагається коректно спланувати
та здійснити забудову
За словами ініціаторів
новий інвестор усвідомлює значимість проекту
і зможе забудувати історичний квартал
належним чином
Якщо ж його змусять вийти з проекту
чекпойнт Чарлі чекають, щонайменше,
іще років десять хаосу
Ми з 1993 року боремося за те
щоб це місце було гідно увічнене
відповідно до свого значення у світовій політиці
Інвестори банкрутіли один за одним.
Ділянка обтяжена боргами
І ми раді, що знайшовся інвестор
готовий не лише сплатити ці борги
але і створити умови для того, щоб там виник музей холодної війни
Зрештою, там же була гаряча точка світової історії
Зрозуміти її значення можна
лише якщо розповісти історію конфронтації світових ідеологічних блоків
Шанси на реалізацію проекту оцінити складно
а будівництво музею - справа не одного року
Тож найближчим часом цей, так би мовити, "Діснейленд холодної війни"
імовірно, працюватиме й далі